top gee
why I think I fight
do I enjoy it now baby G do you enjoy
training no do I enjoy cutting weight no
am I nervous yes do I think to myself
what am I doing yes
completely unfortunately
it's one of those things you're either
born with you're not
and
the only way I can explain it to make it
make any sense is that if I'm not doing
something which is either extremely
difficult or extremely stressful I'm in
a Perpetual state of crippling boredom I
can't explain it I see other people live
their lives and they're like oh I can't
wait for the weekend because I want to
watch this movie
cares about a movie you know like I feel
the same way and then I'll get trapped
on like social media like looking at
Instagram and I'm like it's [ __ ]
Madness like these apps are meant to
like destroy that inside of you because
if you feel like something's remotely
hard or anything but it's like all right
I can just distract myself from that and
scroll on Instagram for 10 minutes and
then you snap out of it and you're like
what the [ __ ] that was just like 10
minutes of my time just gone to [ __ ] and
it's like I'm so I'm busy I have calls
and stuff like even booking 10 minutes
isn't easy and it's like here I am I
just wasted 10 minutes on this app and
I'm like what the f and you're so much
happier when you're on a call being
productive making a deal having a real
conversation solving problems right like
isn't it so much more fulfilling yeah I
know it is I didn't have that problem
growing up and I can't even imagine like
but that imagine like dealing with that
and then it's like I have to do school
work it's like I could give a [ __ ] about
schoolwork and that's what I have to put
my focus on I'm trying to I'm just
trying to wrap my head around you know
my experience now as somebody with
social media and without like I had had
the other experience I had experiences
if I was if I was procrastinating on my
schoolwork I was sitting I'm going to a
teenage Elena like I was sitting in my
room with you know a new album and all
the lyrics you know that came with all
the lyrics and just sitting there and
reading lyrics listening to the songs
and listening to the whole album through
once and then like going back again and
again that was your procrastination and
that was our procrastination but there
was some depth in that because you know
we were really I don't know we were
studying we were memorizing we were
learning we were music is Art and not
that there isn't good things there
aren't good things on the internet too
but there's a lot of nonsense that
people are really going that deep on and
you know what's funny is that like you
back then looking at something like that
as like procrastination like me now
sitting and like focusing on an album
that's like wow I can't believe I
focused for an hour and I was actually
able to listen to something for an hour
but that was like your mental break I
couldn't wait for Tuesdays because
that's when the new albums came out they
came out on Tuesdays and me and Samantha
really used to be Tuesdays now it's
Fridays Samantha and I used to go and
get go to the record store and pick out
the latest thing because we read it in
the magazine what was coming out it was
very exciting life was simpler it was
easier to get to what he said young boy
drops fourth album of the year to get to
what he said I really agree I'm happier
when my schedule is so packed that I
wake up in the morning and I think oh my
God how am I going to get through this
and get anything done I get more done
yeah no you're right that's why like
student athletes end up doing better
with for the most part because like
you're busy so you have to manage your
time better you know you have to you
have to go to school and then you have
to like figure out where to work in um
your homework and [ __ ] but if you have
like nothing to do all day you're just
like I'll do it later and then you just
end up never doing it right you ever ask
ready to do something that's never got
anything that that has nothing to do
when you think well they have plenty of
time they can get it done and they don't
so Patty our landlord I won't say her
last name used to say you know if you
want something done ask a busy person
ask somebody that's got way too much on
their plate put put it on their plate
they'll take care of it for you or
they'll get somebody to take care of it
for you so I anyway I do find it so much
more satisfying to have a full
jam-packed day and like this like I
can't wait for the weekend to watch that
movie like he's right sad it's so sad
like all the time people like you have
to watch this show you got to watch that
show you got to watch this yeah I want
to go to I want to go to Europe like oh
I might get a week off in like six
months it's like damn dude that sounds
horrible yeah but like it just you know
it's so funny I'm not taking the time to
watch TV unless it's going to be
something enriching unless it's some
Jesus [ __ ] or something yeah well yeah I
do watch 100 Jesus yeah you're looking
forward to the weekend for a movie for a
movie four to the weekend to get drunk
like these things to me are so mundane
they mean nothing and if I don't fight
if I'm not in a situation where I'm
stressed or worried or concerned
and just perpetually bored and boredom's
crippling if you're an intelligent
person and you've got a good brain on
your shoulders you can't just sit there
bored
so most smart people take the academic
group to avoid boredom they learn learn
but that's never really interesting to
me
either although I've always been an
intelligent guy I've always done well
academically it never really interested
me and then I see people climb Mount
Everest or jump off buildings or do base
jumping or the guy who jumped from space
people think what's he doing he's crazy
I understand because some people can
live normal life some people cannot just
function nine to five office jobs get
drunk on the weekends that is not for
some individuals and it's not for me
it's not for anybody you have to find
someone anybody that's doing that is
unhappy ultimately if you're just living
to get drunk on the weekend and you're
spending the first five days of your
week like trudging through just to get
through just to create a weekend that
you forget because you got so drunk
you're really not truly satisfied in
life no not at all it's so it's awful
[ __ ] lame like I was just in the club
in Miami we went to um someplace in
Brickell and like I'm it's mad expensive
and then I'm standing there and it's
like you can't hear [ __ ] you got your
drink and it's just like I don't know
you're standing at the table and it's
like I don't know like I was kind of
with like business people I didn't know
know too well like maybe if I was with
like good friends it would be a lot more
fun like Hometown friends in the Miami
clubs where you could just like shoot
[ __ ] and be like this is so cool like
we're usually just like chilling at home
maybe that would be cooler but it's like
well you can't hear anybody it's like
these girls are all like on the dance
floor dancing with dudes it's like I
don't want to talk to you and then it's
like you know what I mean you can't even
hear them
yeah I could see you standing at a club
in a music in a in a place where the
music's too loud to talk with Matthew
and Joseph and something happens and the
three of you look at each other and have
an entire conversation with just your
eyes and you're having a ball but when
you're there with people you don't know
that well it sucks like I met her at the
club though look at that let's see
that's something she never texted me
back though you can do better hello
there it is funny I've gotten some some
DMS lately oh more oh wait let's talk
about your DMs because I love them
remember that catfish one you got that
wasn't a cat totally real she's not real
yeah she's real
and someone took her photo and pretended
to be her no no I am
all right I'll FaceTime her just to
prove to you yes let's get around let's
get her on a podcast and see how real
she is let's see
let's see who are some other ones slide
like shooting DMS doesn't work like I
have to receive them first or else it's
just like it doesn't work it it is it's
it's hard I gotta we gotta say it again
because I don't mean to I don't mean to
be rude and not respond to people when
they write to me but we've been getting
a lot of DMS and I I just did I even
show you it's hard to respond to all of
them I mean I I try to even dip into the
comments here and there and try to
respond here and there and I'm glad I do
but this is not easy read this someone
emailed me just wanted to know if your
mom's single I reside in Australia and
have Turkish Heritage yes I am Muslim
apologies if she's taken cordially yours
an Australian Turk who lives prospective
he sent his name and he said prospect
prospective stepfather as like this like
the sincerely sort of on the other side
of the earth you have nothing in common
with me but you why are you emailing
those things you know and you're and
you're texting my son about my single
dumb or not should I just be like yeah
0.58 for phone number
I'll kill you
[ __ ] him
you know what don't don't get mad about
it don't get mad don't get mad I mean
it's it's a compliment and I'm grateful
for it but it's it's not the way to meet
a lady like it's cringe bro you're so
delusional to stop me going at you all
don't be mean to your face I'm mentally
tired enough no I've chosen fighting
because without this when I'm not in
training I wake up every day and think
okay what do I do today it's 9 A.M on
Tuesday I'm bored everyone's at work I'm
bored and I'll end up doing something
crazy I'll leave it up drunk or on the
Eurostar or you know it's just it's just
a random lifestyle because I'm
constantly looking for never-ending
entertainment it doesn't exist I think
the only thing that could stop me
fighting him is if I had enough money to
constantly entertain myself unless I'm a
billionaire I need something that keeps
me focused and keeps me occupied in life
with fighting I have to train twice a
day and I have to train hard and the
stress can be the stress it brings in
every aspect can replace fun and my mind
is occupied it occupies me it's the only
way I can try and explain it it occupies
me I could never stop doing this even if
I lost 100 fights because I'm not built
to live a normal existence I can't do it
I couldn't just have a kid with some
girls I feel that yeah I really do work
a little bit and relax I've never
relaxed in my entire life I don't know
what relaxing is it's just normal
[Music]
top [ __ ] gee
yeah I don't I I kind of feel some of
what he said I was a four-time kickball
I love working for 12 years five hours a
day six days a week and I was motivated
to train probably about 25 of the time
the rest of the time I went because I am
disciplined you don't feel like going
through that [ __ ] on a Wednesday morning
when you wake up and you have to do it
because you're disciplined you're either
a disciplined individual or you are not
a disciplinary
there's there's a difference between
want and want and I say this all the
time people say to me I want to be rich
and I say okay well I want to be able to
ice skate but I don't want to be able to
ice skate enough to go learn how to ice
skate because I can't be bothered I mean
surely if I could click my fingers and
be a figure skater I'd click my fingers
who wouldn't but I don't want to
actually go train is this because it's I
don't I don't want it enough
and this is exact point with money
everyone wants money put on their lap if
you truly wanted money you wouldn't be
able to sleep until you [ __ ] had it
and this is the point because when I had
nothing I couldn't be distracted you
couldn't distract me from what I wanted
that's who I am if I want something I'm
going to get it I I do not need to be
motivated I'm a disciplined person if I
allocate x amount of time to work I'm
gonna do it but that is the bottom line
answer it's discipline you're going to
have to work when you don't feel like
working
that's how it's going to have to be or
you're never going to be eating
one of the only things in this world
control is your state of mind you can't
control the weather you can't control
other people you can't even control your
health you might get a brain hemorrhage
or you might get hit by a bus one of the
very few things in the world you have
genuine control of is your state of mind
you decide if you're a disciplined
person you decide if you're a happy
person you decide if you're a depressed
person these are things that in real
time you can affect in your brain this
is all you can control on Earth if you
can't control that then you're just a
feather in the wind and life's gonna
blow you around and you might land
somewhere good you might land in dog
[ __ ] nobody knows the state of mind is
what you should be able to control if
you can't wake up and say today I'm
making some money and actually try your
very very best and actually stay
dedicated to that task if you can't do
that
every man understands you shouldn't be
complaining about things you cannot
change you have to play the card to go
to be born a certain height and then to
sit there and go what do I do I'll tell
you what you do you become the best
version of yourself just like everyone
else does nothing about the hype is in
and of itself enough value for me to be
a valuable man as a man you build your
value you are born with the cards you're
dealt sure it'd be ideal look I'd love
to be seven foot tall I'm not so it's
the same argument if you're five foot
two you need to become rich strong and
funny and Charisma and interesting and
witty if you're six foot four you need
to become rich strong well connected
it's the same game so to sit there and
complain about it I love this so much
like the way I like completely changed
my mind is like I used to grind like
Grand Theft Auto and I will build up my
weed Farms I start with a little farm
and then I'd go to a factory and then
have a couple factories and you'd be
managing the weed Farms then you get a
cocaine Farm you know I'd be grinding
that and it's like with life you can
like post a video and then every view
that's like a new person and that like
sees your face and then like the next
time they see you or you're marketing
something they're more likely to buy a
product or if you're making a new
connection or you know you have a new
editor you you know someone else that
can provide a service then the next
person that might need that service
that's another way you can make money
you could up charge that person like if
you just constantly look for new stuff
every day like each entrepreneurial
video you watch you gain something new
you know what I mean like it's a whole
video game in itself just playing the
life of Life [ __ ] rather than just
looking at your phone and scrolling all
day like most people do like you can
make that productive every lift every
[ __ ] weight you lift building nothing
can be productive you know I do squats
while I brush my teeth right I'm sure
you've seen me doing this dumb stuff
yeah you do your table push-ups I do my
table I do my kitchen counter push-ups
yeah I'm I whatever but but still I make
everything productive if I'm standing at
the kitchen sink washing dishes and I'm
waiting for the water to get hot I'm
doing push-ups against the kitchen
counter saying don't waste time
everything and that gets me to where I
want to be Fitness wise like there's
like there's so many different little
things you can do like I could like
optimize my routine and then that that
makes it so like I'm more productive
throughout the day like there's so many
like I can join this program and have a
stronger Network I can make a Google doc
to keep track of this whole network yeah
like make deals I make deals with myself
I can do this once I've done that like I
watch a bot video like if I'm watching
some garbage content it's like well I
could be watching like Tate or something
where you actually gain some value like
there's so many things so many things so
many ways to spend your time that are
protective like there's so yourself good
for your family there's so much I want
to do and I feel like such [ __ ] when I'm
like when I have an unproductive day and
I don't do it because like I want to
have like a ton of money and then like
my goals are like I want to be like
really good at the guitar one day I
eventually want to like make music you
know maybe have like a TV show like so
much like random [ __ ] that people would
never think but it's like all part of
the journey all right all right but
don't don't beat yourself up you're
[ __ ] 19 years old you work very hard
and sometimes your body and your mind
are literally tired like there's it's
legit tired and rest is a good thing
everybody rests the the toughest
warriors on the planet rest and you know
what I'm gonna do they only sleep in
between in between in lulls and battle
and they'll sleep for 40 minutes and
wake up and like go back to battling for
a day a full day but you have to you
have to take rest in order to it's just
plugging in so don't beat yourself up on
the days that you need a little rest
just don't just don't become a wrestler
I have some bad news what we weren't
recording what you never hit the record
no I'm playing oh dude I'm just busting
your boss because I'm like I gotta go I
gotta go to dinner we gotta go oh yeah
wrap it up cousin Gina gets mad because
I'm always late I can't even complain
about it it's asinine
all of you have a hand for this I don't
think you understand that you could have
been in a car crash at four years old
and lost your legs you have any
understanding of how lucky you have been
this is pure luck there's no re there's
only luck has kept you fully able-bodied
sitting there capable of learning and
listening and becoming something you
don't really need to be that tall if
you're important and Rich and when you
walk in the room you think when [ __ ]
Mayweather walks in the room people give
a [ __ ] fix that frame in your mind you
are viewing yourself as a short man stop
it walk the [ __ ] up and be the man
[ __ ]
when your weight
where does laundry away mean give Tate a
rating one to ten
twelve top G can't believe you gave him
like a five or six at first that's
hilarious I'm still mad about the
father's funeral don't get me started
all right I'll see you guys later Paseo
do you only had one father we died he
didn't go to the funeral that's it
between that I told you this video
wouldn't be quick all right peace
[Music]
[Music]